like many others in Paris on Sunday this
is a place of morning The Bella keep a
small cafe we all live in this
neighborhood it was the birthday of one
of my friends we always met up here city
we can see that I just don't understand
it I don't understand
19 people died here they were gunned
down on the pavement where flowers now
carpet the ground it was about 9 p.m.
when armed men got out of a car and
started firing worth much I Beatrice
daughter I live directly opposite I saw
how they shot them I heard the shots and
I hit my daughter because I knew they
can hit you anywhere that's girly it's
ridiculously by lafayette kettle bullet
holes in the walls The Bella keep was
one of the last to be hit and the police
took a while to get here by that time
the attackers were long gone just [ __ ]
your perp a machine e you can't imagine
it yeah these there were bodies all over
the place there there where the flowers
are there was blood all over the floor
she is it the EcoP I came to help there
was nothing I could do I just have been
buzzed use them I don't even know
whether anyone survived me city it's
unbelievable it was just full of bodies
this morning someone drew this sign on a
wall near the cafe it's the new symbol
of Paris and its people a sign of peace
and solidarity after a night of horror